habt ihr noch gekriegt hallo mein name
ist herzlich willkommen wir heute zu
einem neuen video ist und sie sind nicht
alleine in einer neuen location alle die
heute anders herum eigentlich ist auf
jeden fall mit dabei
und genau hier setzen wir auf jeden fall
auch nicht heute sondern als anna hat
uns fragen über youtube rausgesucht das
aber nicht das einzige was leute haben
sondern ich habe auch noch die wühlmäuse
gekauft zwei packungen das heißt jeder
von uns beiden bekommt gleich eine volle
packung liegen heute ähnlich wie
marshmallows glutenfrei laktosefrei
natürlicher farben einfach geil auf
jeden fall bekommen wir jetzt vielleicht
fragen gestellt und das sind eher sagen
also es geht so um wie viele jobs macht
er genau genug und wer von uns beiden
näher dran liegt man hat quasi die runde
dann gewonnen und der verlierer muss ich
war eine riesen maus in den mund stopft
das ganze heißt frank wallisellen zh das
gut allerdings früher so gemacht
die vier jahren oder so er wurde halt
irgendwie so gemacht dass man sich die
quasi im mund gesteckt und shabani sagen
müsste wir machen das aber mit ein paar
fragen damit das ganze ein bisschen
anders
bottrop
so können wie viel arbeit zu
wir haben am nächsten dran ist ja ich
würde sagen wir beide sind jetzt von
mega viel alter kanzlerin bleiben also
beauty guide ist ihr der kanal nur die
meisten momenten dass ich würde sagen
einfach auf 3 und so mache das selbst
von 53 millionen auf 55 35 24 350
millionen und die richtige antwort
also wird das war ganz schön schwer aber
wenn ich sage immer wenn jemand nicht an
dem aus dem mund gesteckt hat muss man
war von crafter kenne ich hier so lange
das fixe domain youtube.com auch schon
hat die youtube online listet 34 15
jahre gesagt also hast du elf jahre 2002
den weg zum grundschule früher das war
glaube ich in der dritten klasse da
wurde mir gesagt die webseite youtube
und dann hab ich gefragt wie youtube.com
und da wartet auf jeden fall würde das
dann quasi domain war und die sache ist
das hat ja quasi 10 11
[Musik]
elf oder zwölf jahre her
letztens sogar noch neue sprache
überhaupt dass ich direkt verloren ja ok
kommen
ich hätte jetzt echt wieder 40 oder so
guckt aber sonst qualcomm kräfte wie
viele einnahmen hat im juni 2015 vor
steuer ab ich habe 15
minute und die videomaterial in
steinhöring minuten wird das youtube
hochgeladen 2006
[Musik]
ich dachte dort ist alles gedacht die
stündliche schon hochladen ich habe
genau diese pro sekunde kommen wie
vielen stunden werden abgerufen
das natürlich mehr angesehen wird als
hochgeladen
ich bin ja jeden mann
die aufrufe zeigt die die steve elle 6
die böcke hofladen das video des bundes
übertragen und ab 2012 nicht mehr oder
weniger sagen dass ich die zähne
verloren habe ich wollte eigentlich
heute können wir auf jeden fall der
stelle sagen danke für zuschauer mit
durchgefallen man leider an der
beschreibung von mir ein wort sehr gut
verlinkt
der könnte eine ewigkeit bitte